[Música]
dentro de pocos días el 23 de junio se
cumplen ya 6 años desde que no referendo
el pueblo británico tomó una decisión
sin precedentes dejar de ser parte de la
unión europea desde entonces los ires y
venires los aciertos y desaciertos
acuerdos y desacuerdos han sido la
constante en la relación entre londres y
bruselas que tiene a irlanda del norte
en el centro de las discrepancias si
bien este país hace parte del reino
unido- comparte la misma isla con la
república de irlanda que es un país que
pertenece a la unión europea el punto
clave de la negociación entre las partes
fue la frontera precisamente entre las
dos irlandas el acuerdo alcanzado fue
una frontera blanda es decir irlanda del
norte que es parte del reino unido-
seguir haciéndolo pero no tendría una
frontera física con irlanda para así
garantizar cierto flujo comercial es
decir irlanda del norte en palabras más
palabras menos seguiría vinculada al
mercado común de la unión europea pero
el gobierno del primer ministro boris
johnson presentó a la cámara de los
comunes un proyecto de ley que podría
permitir modificar de manera unida el
protocolo de irlanda del norte que a su
vez es un protocolo que está pactado
dentro del acuerdo del presi y
establecería algunos cambios en el
manejo de esa frontera se lo explicamos
mejor a continuación
un proyecto de ley que tiene al reino
unido- cerca de desatar una nueva crisis
con la unión europea este lunes el
gobierno británico presentó su propuesta
de modificación del régimen aduanero de
irlanda del norte un protocolo negociado
al momento del break city para permitir
a irlanda del norte quedarse en el
mercado único europeo sin restablecer
una frontera con la república de irlanda
el texto prevé permitir la libre
circulación de mercancías británicas
destinadas a irlanda del norte pero al
mismo tiempo mantener los impuestos y
controles de las que vayan dirigidas a
la república de irlanda por ejemplo nos
tomamos muy en serio esta legislación si
soluciona los problemas del protocolo de
irlanda del norte también protege al
mercado único de la unión europea por lo
que la unión europea no sale perjudicada
por esta legislación es de slash station
sin embargo la unión europea declaró que
está firmemente opuesta a cualquier
cambio de la legislación e incluso
amenazó con tomar represalias
austin of de protocolo y andrea listica
la renegociación del protocolo no es
realista no se ha encontrado ninguna
solución alternativa viable para este
delicado equilibrio largamente negociado
cualquier renegociación simplemente
traería más incertidumbre para la gente
en las empresas de irlanda del norte por
esta razón en la unión europea no
renegociará el protocolo for the streets
de euros
dos sets de protocolo el gobierno
británico dijo estar dispuesto a
negociar con la unión europea pero
afirmó que necesita arreglar estos
problemas en irlanda del norte lo antes
posible
preguntas que quedan entonces sobre la
mesa que busca johnson con esta
propuesta un acuerdo a su medida bajar
un poco también las aguas con referencia
al escándalo del partido que lo ha
afectado recientemente qué opciones
tiene entonces la unión europea está
dispuesta a negociar con londres o se
mantendrá con una postura mucho más
fuerte y firme frente a lo acordado
previamente con el reino unido- y en
medio de las discusiones alguien se ha
puesto a pensar en irlanda del norte que
significa estar en medio de toda esta
situación a qué sanciones se está
exponiendo londres con este cambio en
este pacto alcanzado con bruselas como
se verá afectado el comercio johnson ha
hecho un cálculo de las consecuencias en
términos políticos de lo que le podría
traer este tipo de discrepancias con la
unión europea la factura tal vez se la
van a cobrar un poco más adelante muchos
puntos para analizar hoy en el debate de
france 24 el reino unido- versus la
unión europea para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a oscar guardiola él es
escritor y profesor en ver que college
university of london se encuentra en la
ciudad de londres que la capital del
reino unido y desde ciudad de mexico se
conecta dámaso morales ramírez él es
coordinador del centro europeo de la
facultad de ciencias políticas de la
universidad autonoma de mexico ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte de esta conversación estamos a
través de las redes sociales ustedes ya
las conocen estamos en facebook también
no se encuentran en instagram y en
twitter y también pueden ver nuestras
señales en streaming a través de youtube
nos encuentran como france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate efe 24
comienzos entonces dándole la bienvenida
a oscar guardiola en la ciudad de
londres oscar gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa y el punto de partida
como me gusta llamar a esta primera
pregunta para el debate para conocer
posiciones porque esta posición del
reino unido porque cambiará ahora este
acuerdo ya alcanzado que tanto costó
negociar está a boris johnson
simplemente buscando un cambio
unilateral para
y modificarlo a su manera sabiendo que
es un documento que él firmó él aprobó
quizás la mejor manera de entender lo
que está haciendo bolillos en este
momento es tomar en cuenta en el
contexto político
que
enmarca esta decisión
boris johnson viene de un par de semanas
muy difíciles en las cuales casi pierde
un voto de no confianza iniciado por su
propio partido
así que su reto es intentar sobrevivir a
como dé lugar y para hacerlo tienen que
hacer dos cosas el primero dado que no
va a ser posible
hacerle llegar a sus
electores un
premio material pues la economía
británica en general cada vez da signos
de entrada en una situación más compleja
va a intentar
y darles como ha sido usual en su estilo
de gobierno una suerte de premios
símbolo y ese premio simbólico consiste
en volver a enfrentarse al himno a la
unión europea cee de la otra parte claro
que hay una serie de temas políticos que
implican a irlanda del norte el hecho de
que en irlanda del norte el unionismo es
decir
el sentimiento de seguir perteneciendo
al resto de gran bretaña está de capa
caída y va bajando cada vez más y en
cambio el nacionalismo de sinn fein
va hacia arriba sí así que también se
trata de ese problema político que puede
convertirse en un problema
constitucional para el reino unido- la
posible separación de una parte del
reino unido y claro esos son los temas
políticos que enmarcan esta decisión que
consiste en otra cosa sino en atacar
subrayó el protocolo como bien lo
dijiste él mismo lo negoció si fue un
protocolo que él mismo firmó y que en su
momento consideró como un gran éxito
negociador por parte del reino unido
donde en esta relación de gran a ghana
según él el reino unido tenía ahí
ciertas ventajas y era beneficioso para
el reino unido dámaso morales en ciudad
de méxico bienvenido al programa gracias
por acompañarnos y pregunta para el
punto de partida porque esta posición
del reino unido porque esta jugada de
boris johnson ya óscar nos daba sus
puntos de vista cuáles son los suyos
[Música]
si sin lugar a dudas boris johnson se
encuentra ahorita en la encrucijada
política nacional y ahora ya se ha
puesto también en la encrucijada
política internacional
esta situación del llamado barrio gates
y por lo cual dio lugar precisamente a
ambos obsesión para quitarle la
confianza y que finalmente boris johnson
pudo lograr salvarla no significa de
ningún modo de que ya tenga la situación
controlada y por ello precisamente ahora
avanza en este tema pero es un tema
bastante bastante delicado que también
puede despertar viejas rencillas viejas
situaciones en la isla de irlanda como
tal precisamente que derivaron en estos
acuerdos de viernes santo pero que creo
que sabemos que están ahí y que no ha
sido necesariamente la solución perfecta
entonces volver en el dedo en la llaga'
respecto de esta situación le puede
salir a boris johnson bastante caro
vemos que ya se han pronunciado miembros
de su propio partido en relación a esta
iniciativa de ley a esta propuesta de
ley en sentido contrario y se dicen que
definir entre este puesto no sería quizá
la mejor idea que habría que trabajar en
ella y aún así lo que está empeñada es
la palabra del gobierno del reino unido
en la comunidad internacional y la
palabra el reino unido- pesa y debería
pesar ya lo decía yo en la introducción
dámaso esto le puede pasar factura a
boris johnson y también al reino unido
no en este momento en un futuro cercano
puede empezar a cobrar las facturas en
diferentes áreas sigo con dámaso para
hacer la ronda a la inversa y quiero que
manejemos este tema de adentro hacia
afuera de lo más pequeño hasta llegar al
tema ya ha visto desde la óptica de la
unión europea y desde el punto de vista
de bruselas hablo de boris johnson
dámaso habló del momento político en el
que él está para tener que hacer este
tipo de jugadas como ustedes lo han
explicado a raíz del partido cómo se
encuentra la popularidad de johnson
entre los británicos entre su partido a
nivel político hay un declive o esto es
una forma las patadas de ahogado
digámoslo así para mantenerse
sin lugar a dudas no está en su mejor
momento político tanto que su propio
partido
promulgó e inició precisamente esta
moción para quitarle la confianza de
alguna manera siendo sensibles a la voz
pública a la opinión pública de lo
desastroso que fue digamos este asunto
de estas fiestas durante la pandemia y
el manejo que yo boris johnson que no
fue precisamente el de hablar con toda
la verdad ni el de justificar un asunto
importantísimo que es el de la confianza
la confianza político política es un
activo el dentro de la política del
reino unido hay una hay una cultura de
confianza el confiar en el otro y esta
es parte fundamental de cómo se ven
ellos mismos en ese sentido
moriyón son sin lugar a dudas este pues
no ha manejado bien esta situación su
popularidad no está en su mejor momento
definitivamente es real
al contrario yo creo que vuelve a abrir
una nueva puerta de debate y que también
sin lugar a dudas va a tener resultados
negativos sobre su propia persona porque
finalmente la emoción no se terminó en
la votación la discusión puede revivir
en alguna manera con todo este proceso y
si además tomamos en cuenta que hay
divisiones entre su propio partido
entonces sin lugar a dudas esto va este
restante complicado
óscar lópez yo nada más hay una pérdida
de confianza o por lo menos ciertas
críticas por parte de diferentes
sectores políticos y también dentro de
los ciudadanos británicos pero el
proceder de johnson siempre ha sido así
no ir un poco en contra de los
protocolos de la forma de hacer política
tradicional en el reino unido- un poco
en contra de la corriente tal vez este
es otro ejemplo de esa forma de el de
gobernar y llevar su país
eso es correcto johnson es una suerte de
populista de derechas y en buena medida
eso es lo que lo llevó al poder le
permitió derrotar a una firme oposición
de izquierdas sin embargo tal parecería
que su apelación a la confianza
el bromear simplemente llevar la
contraria
no le estaría dando la misma atracción
que le había dado antes en este momento
el partido conservador se encuentra por
debajo en todas las encuentras del
partido laborista y eso que el partido
laborista no ha hecho mayor oposición
así que esto es simplemente el resultado
de el mismo disparándose en su pie como
se dice aquí en inglaterra
en efecto no es solamente el partido y
la pérdida de confianza que además de
ser una manera como se ven los
británicos como bien decía dámaso
también es un elemento importante a la
hora de valorar los bienes económicos
dado que se trata en últimas de
contratos de acuerdos y esto va desde
adentro hacia afuera pero también hay en
este momento una crisis muy grave de los
costos de vida que están sintiendo en su
bolsillo cada uno de los británicos y
tal parece parece que en la isla de
irlanda en particular milán en irlanda
del norte el hecho de que irlanda del
norte continúe siendo parte de la unión
económica está produciendo unos efectos
económicos diferentes y esa diferencia
le va a hacer clara al votante británico
la próxima vez la próxima vez que vaya a
las urnas y es por eso que yo solo está
en problemas
oscar me subo un escalón más saliendo
nos de downing street de londres y me
paso al reino unido- el contexto y las
discrepancias que también ya está
generando dentro del reino unido- vemos
a escocia bastante inconforme con las
decisiones que está tomando londres ya
incluso la ministra encargada o ministra
de escocia ha vuelto a poner sobre la
mesa esa posibilidad de un referendo de
independencia escocia quiere ser parte
de la unión europea y londres pues ha
tomado esta decisión y pese a que hubo
un referendo allí en escocia también hay
cierta incomodidad
en irlanda del norte por todas estas
discusiones que se dan con bruselas y
ellos en la mitad a nivel de la unidad
del reino unido- este tema cómo se está
manejando esto está generando una
fractura que podríamos estar comenzando
a ver hay fisuras que podría llevar a
una desintegración del reino tal vez
sin lugar a duda estamos viendo los
primeros salvos de lo que va a ser una
crisis política y una crisis
constitucional
muchos ya habíamos predicho con
antelación que el hecho de que londres
westminster inglaterra lo hubiese
impuesto tanto a escocia como hablando
del norte un brasil que
ninguno de los electores en estos en
estas dos naciones de reino unido había
aceptado iba por supuesto a azuzar los
sentimientos nacionalistas en ambas
naciones y eso es exactamente lo que
está ocurriendo las últimas elecciones
locales en irlanda del norte le dieron
un triunfo considerable a él
nacionalismo irlandés el sinn fein y
ustedes tienen que tomar en cuenta lo
que esto implica tanto en términos
históricos como en términos de la
obligación que tendría londres de llevar
a cabo un referendo acerca de si irlanda
del norte se quiere unir o no
al resto a la república de irlanda
que es pues parte de los acuerdos de
viernes santo la fuerza de paz al que se
refirió dama zona y no es ninguna
coincidencia que al mismo tiempo en el
exterior la primera ministra escocesa
hubiese sugerido que podría también
llevar a cabo un referendo similar el
año entrante así que lo que estamos
viendo es una suerte de tormenta
perfecta que empieza a rodear el
gobierno conservador de boris johnson el
único que estaría escapando un poco a
estas discrepancias sería gales que
todavía no ha tomado como una posición
muy marcada frente a la posición que ha
tomado a londres dámaso su opinión sobre
esta tormenta perfecta que describe
oscar en su explicación y su análisis
sobre la internet
digámoslo la cohesión del reino unidos a
la palabra que quería decir la cohesión
del reino unido a raíz de este problema
claro sin lugar a dudas yo coincido con
lo que menciona a oscar respecto a la
posibilidad de una crisis constitucional
porque eso es lo que estaríamos quizá
sabiendo si se abre un debate y se
amplía precisamente este debate y
particularmente la historia de irlanda
porque es una historia pues muy
diferente
cada estamos esta historia como un
catolicismo el estar ellos mismos en una
isla pero la forma en que irlanda del
norte forma parte por así que el reino
unido en estos acuerdos de viernes santo
que buscaron poner fin entre estos
guionistas a las crías de referencia
oscar y los nacionalistas que buscan
precisamente recuperar la identidad de
esas lenguas sus tradiciones su propia
religión católica y esto sin lugar a
dudas en lo que pudiera es abrir la caja
de pandora
precisamente porque en los propios
acuerdos de viernes santo se establece
que es el propio pueblo irlandés el que
tendría que definir el futuro de la
región y también en este protocolo sobre
irlanda que se pero no en el marco del
éxito también se establece que el pueblo
y la asamblea norirlandesa tendría que
verificar por hay del 24 más son
nacionales del 24
o no continuar con el protocolo un visto
de esta manera se está dando la voluntad
precisamente la soberanía sobre este
asunto al pueblo irlandés y norirlandés
dependiendo el caso para hacer una
definición sobre su futuro y esto sí se
suma al ambiente político precisamente
de escocia que como bien muy apuntaba a
buscar votaron por permanecer en la
unión europea y está este ánimo de
alguna manera público de que escocia
pudieras de una vez más poder buscar
este referéndum para continuar o no en
el reino unido creo que es un juego
bastante perverso de un poco por parte
de boris johnson pero hay que recordar
que la forma política de boris johnson
es sin terminar el precipicio lo hizo en
todo el proceso de negociación con
europea lo hace siempre de manera común
así trabaja el lleva todo hasta el
precipicio que él mismo ve el precipicio
como para empujar y radicalizar las
acciones
y sacar la mejor tajada veamos y si le
resulta sobre bueno hasta con el manejo
de la pandemia fue así intentó tener una
inmunidad de rebaño en el reino unido
hasta que él mismo quedó contagiado en
un abuso hospitalizado y ahí ya empezó a
tomar medidas y apostarle a la
vacunación masiva para hacerle frente a
la pandemia de kobe el 19 mes hubo un
escalón más pasó entonces a las
instancias europeas y allí quiero
conocer a dámaso su opinión sobre esta
pregunta que ponía yo sobre la mesa en
la introducción del programa alguien ha
pensado en irlanda del norte- alguien le
ha preguntado a belfast qué puede hacer
en esta situación qué medidas pueden
tomar ellos en esta negociación que van
a tener que hacer londres y bruselas si
es que la hay si es que bruselas permite
una negociación y no activa mecanismos
para poder hacer que estas salvaguardas
de este acuerdo se lleven a cabo y
forzar un poco al reino unido- a
respetar el acuerdo que pueda ser
irlanda del norte- entonces en toda esta
negociación
y bueno como ya había notado el área del
norte está facultada precisamente en
pozo asamblea de tomar una decisión
dentro de algunos años de si permanece o
no en este protocolo sino que continúa
en este protocolo irlanda que como bien
se apuntaba al inicio al programa acción
protocolo sumamente complicado difícil
de de sumar distintas posiciones y sobre
todo le respetará el espíritu
precisamente de viernes santo de no
establecer una una frontera dura sin
embargo este pues sabemos
desde la visión de boris johnson y de
algunos de sus correligionarios ellos
están viendo que necesita recuperar el
mercado de irlanda y necesita recuperar
la soberanía del reino unido sobre
irlanda
particularmente por supuestos casos de
las normas de la unión europea tropicana
en irlanda de la jurisdicción del
tribunal europeo y otros asuntos
entonces el puesto de esta manera
e irlanda finalmente un punto histórico
es precisamente el de mantener esta
frontera abierta la propuesta de ley de
boris johnson estaría cambiando
precisamente estas partes del juego y de
una negociación que sin lugar a dudas
formó parte del acuerdo de retirada del
praxis en su conjunto y que en ese
sentido pues estarían vulnerando no
solamente el propio acuerdo del bcie
sino también se estaría vulnerando la
voluntad del propio pueblo irlandés hay
que decir sin embargo que desde hace
varios días la asamblea en este
norirlandesa permanece pues cerrada
francamente precisamente porque no haya
no han habido estos acuerdos entre estos
gobiernos de ambos bandos precisamente
en temas como este y de hecho sobre este
tema entonces sí sí hay también un gran
debate dentro de la propia irlanda del
norte sobre este tema y que por lo que
vimos que se cerró la asamblea
no es nada fácil
no es nada fácil me subo un escalón más
oscar allí en la ciudad de londres paso
a hablar ahora de la comisión europea me
voy de belfast hasta bruselas porque
allí la comisión ya ha reactivado ese
procedimiento de infracción
esto quiere decir que le da dos meses al
reino unido para que se retracte de este
tipo de
modificaciones que le quieran hacer a
este protocolo a este acuerdo alcanzado
hasta dónde puede llegar bruselas que
implican estas infracciones contra el
reino unido por por no respetar los
acuerdos pactados qué medidas puede
tomar bruselas
fue muy interesante escuchar hace unas
horas al
ministro de la comisión europea para ver
a los chefs como bitch quien para unir
esto con la pregunta anterior si ha
visitado a irlanda y de hecho en la
rueda de prensa le pedía a los
periodistas británicos que le
preguntasen a los inversionistas y a los
empresarios y los ciudadanos irlandeses
y norirlandeses qué es lo que ellos
quieren
la estrategia de la comisión europea
parece ser el doble de un lado la
zanahoria de otro lado el el palo con el
que puede golpear
el palo significa como lo dijiste a su
momento reactivar dos procedimientos
contra violaciones que habrían cometido
en el pasado el gobierno británico al no
realizar los chequeos
fronterizos
están acordados en el protocolo y de esa
de esa manera le hace llegar el mensaje
al gobierno británico que va a utilizar
las vías judiciales
para penalizarlo esto podría llegar a
implicar una serie de
medidas de carácter económico la corte
europea de justicia puede imponerle una
serie de sanciones económicas que
debería pagar el gobierno británico al
mismo tiempo 6º bis hizo claridad acerca
de que la unión europea está abierta a
aplicar de manera diferente algunas de
las partes del protocolo así que al
mismo tiempo que la unión europea hace
claro que no está dispuesta a renegociar
el tratado dado que fue alcanzado tras
cuatro años de negociaciones
al mismo tiempo
muestra abierta a la ubicación diferente
de protocolo a dar a dar varias
concesiones al reino unido citó algunas
de las palabras de manos de kobe que
tienes el vicepresidente ejecutivo
comunitario responsable de las
relaciones con el reino unido que es la
persona de la que estaba hablando buscar
ha dicho que es inconcebible e
inaceptable este movimiento que daba el
reino unido pero siempre ha dicho que
hay margen para soluciones consensuadas
a condición de que el reino unido acepte
también negociar oscar londres negociar
a
es lo más probable
al final como decía dámaso el estilo de
gobierno de johnson es
hacer que todos contemplen el precipicio
hacerle creer a sus electores que él
está dispuesto a llegar hasta ese orden
si es necesario y en el momento en el
que ya se ve perdido da unos pasos atrás
seguramente en londres va a negociar
seguramente va a atender este llamado
europea a entrar a un tipo de vida te de
bilateralidad para llegar a acuerdos
diferentes sobre la aplicación de
protocolo pero va a tardar en hacerlo
porque como dijimos al comienzo buena
parte de esta de este giro por parte de
lo que se explica es en términos
políticos y johnson en este momento
tiene que volver a dar la apariencia de
ser firme de recuperar como dijo dámaso
anteriormente la posición de londres en
una el norte que además ya se expresó
porque en las elecciones anteriores de
nuevo hace unas tres semanas el pueblo
norirlandés dio su voto mayoritario a el
movimiento nacionalista lo que
implicaría que el apoyo para la
separación de irlanda del norte del
resto de gran bretaña y volver a unirse
a la república de irlanda no está tan
lejos y por supuesto no hemos
contemplado del otro actor importante
acá que son los eeuu sí ya iba a hablar
justamente de eeuu y las implicaciones a
nivel internacional en una siguiente
instancia así en estos dos meses londres
no da marcha atrás a estos reclamos o
este deseo de hacer modificaciones
la unión europea podría llevar esto
justamente hasta la justicia europea que
también tiene competencia y contesta
londres en cierta manera es un escenario
posible dado está estos movimientos de
johnson y esta necesidad de mostrarse
como un hombre fuerte que desafía a la
unión europea que piensa usted de amazon
si se hubiera dudas se podríamos o no
podemos descartar la posibilidad de que
sea una artimaña política de boris
johnson prácticamente la de presionar en
este sentido para obligar a abrir este
protocolo de irlanda y poner algunos de
los elementos que posee el reino unido
estaría buscando si bien es cierto la
unión europea dijo de manera muy clara
que no va a renegociar este protocolo de
irlanda también sabemos sin embargo que
la unión europea siempre se mueve contra
el derecho del derecho internacional del
derecho comunitario y sus propias
instituciones y seguir un camino
burocrático judicial que es la
reactivación precisamente de estas
sanciones la de la reactivación o
incluso el poner otras nuevas sanciones
en el caminito para que llegue al
tribunal de justicia europeo pues forma
parte precisamente de este caminito
burocrático judicial
que en el ínterin se abren estos tiempos
de renegociación o de flexibilización de
ambas partes pero en este caso tenemos
nosotros efectivamente que tomar en
cuenta que no sería una negociación
bilateral de londres reunión europea
sino para ser justos tendría que hacerte
el lateral precisamente contemplando a
los norirlandeses no a lo que es su
voluntad porque estamos hablando ya de
millones y millones de miles de millones
de
euros que es ley
vinculada es precisamente el mercado de
la unión europea inversiones empresas no
es algo fácil que se pueda borrar de un
plumazo de la noche a la mañana no
entonces efectivamente tendría que ser
una negociación muy compleja de las tres
partes ya que usted lo pone sobre la
mesa a oscar hablemos de eeuu que es tal
vez uno de los países que ha jugado como
el gran garante de esos acuerdos del
viernes santo y también
está allí presente para un posible
acuerdo comercial que el reino unido o
sea firmar un acuerdo de libre comercio
entre washington y londres que
precisamente iba a suplir esas
necesidades comerciales que iba a dejar
el reino unido una vez dejara la unión
europea ese acuerdo todavía no ha
llegado no fue acordado durante el
gobierno del presidente de trump y es
una deuda pendiente entre la población
londres washington pero aquí se mete el
componente de irlanda del norte y este
esta acción de eeuu de ser como el gran
garante de estos protocolos que puede
hacer estados unidos allí
irlanda del norte es un tema
importante e interno para la política
estadounidense no es solamente un tema
de política exterior puesto que la
comunidad irlandesa
tiene una gran influencia en el partido
demócrata en particular y de manera aún
más particular en el sector que
representa yo vaivén by the night show
claro cada vez que ha visitado
gran bretaña lo hizo la última vez que
estuvo en glasgow que por supuesto tiene
un interés personal además de político
en la protección de los acuerdos de
viernes santo y el
intento por parte de londres
de manera unilateral desconocer parte de
brasil y hacerlo bajo el pretexto de que
con ello estaría respetando los acuerdos
de bienes de viernes santo constituyen a
con toda claridad para todos los
espectadores incluyendo los estados
unidos una
y una un pretexto que no parece ser
convincente
así que londres se está arriesgando
además a la que sea que le sea llamada a
la atención por parte de su socio
geopolítico más importante si además en
un momento en el que johnson es
percibido en washington como alguien que
estaba más cercano al trono que a los
demócratas su posición no es la mejor en
este caso claro
dámaso para ir cerrando ya el tema me
quedan pocos minutos para el programa
escalo esto a otro piso más arriba y es
como le cae a la unión europea este
problema con londres este movimiento de
boris johnson en la coyuntura en la que
está en este momento en la unión europea
con una guerra
prácticamente al lado de sus fronteras
con unas discrepancias con rusia
no muy cercano con eeuu esa relación
difícil lo tensa o extraña que tiene con
china por él por el contexto en el que
está cómo le cae esto a europa en este
momento
no llevar a dudas es el peor momento de
llevar a cabo una acción como el
activismo boris johnson
particularmente porque en primer lugar
se vulnera así claramente todo el
derecho internacional se vulnera la
palabra se vulnera el honor de reino
unido respecto a otros acuerdos porque
que pudiéramos esperar si se puede
llegar a otro acuerdo que después puede
ser vulnerado nuevamente por el reino
unido y que finalmente pues es su
capacidad su honor digamos si se ve
debilitado y por el otro lado como como
bien apunta esos momentos que se
requiere una gran cooperación y
solidaridad a nivel europeo que incluye
por supuesto el reino unido frente a las
amenazas rusas en ucrania y que pudiera
escalar a otros países y esto sin lugar
a dudas da la idea de una desunión ya no
una desunión netamente jurídica como fue
el break sino una desunión jurídica
política geopolítica pudiera ser en este
sentido
no no es el mejor momento para llevar a
cabo este tipo de acciones
definitivamente además que deja muy mal
parado también al reino unido- frente a
otros socios comerciales sobre el manejo
que le está dando a los acuerdos que
pensaran algunos países africanos que
pensaran algunos de países asiáticos con
los que tiene una estrecha relación
comercial sobre este manejo que ellos
simplemente pues cambian los acuerdos de
forma unilateral a su antojo y a su
beneficio propio me queda un minuto para
hacer las conclusiones comienzo entonces
con oscar en la ciudad de londres que va
a pasar en toda esta disputada no hay
bola de cristal siempre lo digo no
sabemos el futuro de este tipo de
coyunturas pero desde su punto de vista
desde su óptica que cree que va a
suceder entre londres y la unión europea
de dos cosas de una parte johnson está
enfrentando una tormenta política
interna perfecta vamos a ver cómo se
intensifica esa tormenta y esa tormenta
va también a afectar la unión con el
resto de europa que debería ser aparente
en la coyuntura actual las fisuras están
siendo claras y eso por supuesto no es
conveniente no sólo para la unión
europea sino para el resto del mundo y
dámaso en la ciudad de méxico su
conclusión sobre lo que puede suceder en
estas discrepancias
bueno el reino unido va a seguir esta
política que ya implantó boris johnson
hasta donde el alcance de su vida
política que a lo mejor lo vemos caer
antes de lo previsto y por el otro lado
la unión europea
bien como están las constituciones
derecho comunitario va a continuar
digamos este camino y va a tratar de
garantizar por todos los medios
perfectamente estos derechos de irlanda
como isla y de irlanda del norte en
particular pues además hoy a oscar les
agradezco por haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de france 24 habernos
acompañado en el programa ustedes pueden
seguir dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
y por supuesto seguir con la
programación de france 24 siga con
nosotros
[Música]